what do you need to know about marvel's
living vampire before he makes his big
screen debut who's in the cast who's
directing keep watching to find out
everything we know about morbius
morbius was originally set to release in
the summer of 2020 right in the middle
of blockbuster season alongside other
major comic book releases like black
widow and eternals that was a bold
choice but like the rest of the 2020
summer movie season the pandemic got in
the way and sony moved its living
vampire back to the spring of 2021
eventually spring became winter and the
film was bumped up to its current
release date of january 28 2022
filling the lead role of dr michael
morbius is jared leto while he's known
for his sometimes questionable
commitment to his roles we haven't heard
stories of any weird hijinks on the
morbius set just yet what we do know
though is that leto was already a big
fan of vampire stories when he took the
role leto has a long history of
consuming vampire-centered media of
various stripes and has a lot of passion
for the genre from anne rice's interview
with the vampire to bram stoker's
original classic dracula it'll be very
interesting to see how he brings those
influences to the comic book world of
morbius who's a unique vampire character
in his own right i love the opportunity
to do something transformational
arreya rona has been cast as martine
bancroft morbius's fiancee as a
supporting character to the living
vampire who is himself generally not a
leading man it's no surprise that there
isn't exactly a wealth of knowledge
about her to glean from the source
material in the comic stories she often
exists purely to die or be mind
controlled into joining cults giving
morbius sorrow to brood over until she's
resurrected again at one point she also
tried to become a true mythical vampire
and turned on her lover before dying
seemingly for good in this case though
the fact that this lesser-known comic
property doesn't have an expansive lore
could actually work in the project's
favor because it leaves room for a lot
of new invention in the story aro
herself may not be a household name but
she's already got an impressive list of
credits going into morbius you may have
already seen her in shows like true
detective and good omens and films like
pacific rim uprising
matt smith has been cast as the key
villain of morbius his best friend
turned enemy loki's crown who also
suffers from the same blood disease as
the living vampire we don't know much
about the motivations of this character
played by the former time lord but the
disease is fatal so crown certainly has
a lot of desperate motivation to become
the creature morbius is in the comics
crown also goes by the villain name
hunger the character has only appeared
in a few comics but he too is a
pseudo-vampire created by capturing
morbius and experimenting on him to gain
his powers lokis could possibly be a
blend of this villain and morbius's
comics research assistant emil nicos
we'll have to wait and see how the
comics and the films blend on this one
two casting choices from morbius's
supporting characters have piqued our
curiosity tyrese gibson cast as an fbi
agent referred to as agent stroud is
tasked with chasing morbius down in the
wake of his vampiric killing spree then
there's mad men and chernobyl star jared
harris who's been cast as someone
described as morbius's mentor
the first trailer for morbius arrived in
january 2020 with a dark brooding mood
you might expect plus a few interesting
surprises overall the trailer summarizes
morbius's motivation for the film he's
terminally ill and desperate to find a
cure permitting jared leto to get very
broody with the performance hubris is an
underlying theme too with several shots
of morbius receiving awards yet feeling
unsatisfied with the slow progression of
his research that's what drives him to
undertake the absurd steps he does to
cure himself with bats no matter what
his mentor or colleagues say there are a
few intriguing revelations to be found
in the first morbius trailer including a
spider-man easter egg and the return of
michael keaton's vulture but the biggest
surprise might be the revelation that
the source of morbius's vampirism seems
far more mystical than fans perhaps
anticipated he has a weird-looking
ceremonial knife and everything beyond
that we also get glimpses of martine
bancroft who's been upgraded to more
abuse's research assistant for the film
sony pictures describes morbius as a
horror action story about a scientist
trying to cure his own rare blood
disease in the process he accidentally
turns himself into a vampire desperate
for blood he decides to feed on
criminals rather than innocent people in
comics continuity dr michael morbius
attempts to cure his rare blood disease
by inventing a serum distilled from the
vital fluids of bats then hooking up to
an electric line to shock himself as you
might expect this harebrained idea goes
a bit awry and whoops now dr morbius is
a sci-fi vampire that's why he's the
living vampire you see because
science from there morbius's
transformation will make a hero to some
and a villain to others but it's not
clear how he himself will get through it
all
yet at the helm of morbius is daniel
espinoza who was attached at virtually
the same time leto joined the project
his most recognizable director credit in
the united states is for the 2017 alien
horror thriller life but that's not his
only work in his native sweden he
directed the 2010 film easy money and
his other american credits include
safehouse and child 44. on the writing
side of things matsuzama and burke
sharpless handled the script for morbius
after years of working together on other
genre projects their previous credits
include gods of egypt the 2017 power
rangers reboot and dracula untold
we know that morbius is set in the still
developing sony pictures universe of
spider-man supporting characters but
just how much will it connect to the
other spider franchises aside from a
glimpse of horizon labs a fun easter egg
for comics readers who'll recognize the
company where peter parker used to work
the final morbius trailer also makes it
clear that the title character very much
shares a universe with spidey we have an
oscorp sighting affirming that green
goblin norman osborne exists in this mcu
adjacent corner of reality and we also
get another look at whatever's going
down when adrian toombs aka the vulture
meets up with morbius there's also a
daily bugle headline touting morbius's
arrest amid references to other
spider-man characters there's a web of
opportunity this almost certainly only
scratches the surface of what we can
expect in terms of connections between
the various spider-man franchises and we
can't wait to see what's in store
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
superhero movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you